Rio de Janeiro is waking up early
morning is the best time to release
mosquitoes the ones in these cylinders
have been bred in the laboratory and
infected with a certain kind of bacteria
while back here that makes them
incapable of transmitting diseases like
dengue fever the longer-term plan of the
scientists at the world mosquito program
is to infect wild mosquitoes with
wolbachia as well when they go out to
release their infected insects the team
from the world mosquito program has to
make regular stops to get rid of
unwanted passengers an occasional bite
is all part of the job so fighting
against thing is important to avoid
people dying so we know that every time
you have an epidemic in like in that
like tropical countries we know that
many many people die because they have
other problems they have other health
problems
this is what a vector of dengue fever
looks like it's an e DS Egypt E and its
most active during daylight Luanne
Ferreira worries about his baby daughter
Luna dengue is most dangerous in infants
and can often lead to complications
Lewin is pinning his hopes on the
lab-grown mosquitoes the 25 year old is
an ambassador for the world mosquito
program and spends a lot of time raising
awareness in his neighborhood there are
ambassadors like him in all the regions
where reengineered mosquitoes have been
released there has been resistance in
communities because people wanted to
know why more mosquitoes were being
released into the environment when there
are so many biting us already that's
understandable of course why introduce
even more what's the benefit for the
community how does it work but now
they've understood the point of
replacing the natural population of
disease transmitting mosquitoes with
ones that carry Wolbachia dengue fever
is debilitating assad sudan has had it
twice each time it was caused by a
different strain of virus with dengue
you get headaches and fever you can't
eat you have to throw up everyone around
here has had it and then she come Guney
arrived to his sister Amira had a bad
case of chikungunya and took a long time
to recover she had a fever for days and
suffered from joint pain for months
dengue is preferable to chikungunya
that's a disease you have to respect
I wouldn't wish it on anyone I'm
terrified of it
the goal of the scientists at this
mosquito farm is to eliminate
mosquito-borne disease this is where
they infect the insects with Wolbachia
bacteria the females are fed with blood
from conserves past their expiration
date the staff call the lab the mosquito
factory the workflows have been
optimized so that a maximum number of
mosquitoes can be bred here the females
lay their eggs in water cups lined with
paper they're recognizable as black
flecks on the paper
they'll eventually develop into larvae
and mosquitoes
so we loved it we we care about them
like we produce them in a way that can
survive in the field and then place the
the wild population for one that that
has whoa back and then does not transmit
diseases in the neighboring lab
cylinders are filled with a fully
developed mosquito larvae they continue
to mature in the tubes eventually
growing wings one and a half million
mosquitoes are bred every week when
they're released they go on to mate with
a wild mosquito population which carries
disease viruses the project was launched
in September 2014 with three scientists
100 people work here today first we had
the thing it was the only problem then
we had Zika coming chikungunya now
yellow fever is around so if yellow
fever is not urban disease since 1942
but it becomes there is a potential that
it is Egypt I the same vector could
transmit yellow fever in the cities
which will be very complicated
one in five cases of yellow fever proves
fatal health clinics are already at
breaking point there is a yellow fever
vaccine but only 60 percent of
Brazilians are vaccinated
overcrowding is a serious problem in the
favelas of Rio defective water tanks and
overflowing rubbish dumps are ideal
breeding grounds for mosquitoes winters
in Brazil are cool and dry the
mosquitoes take longer to grow even so
it doesn't take Gabriele Sylvester a
long to find some larvae we should be
warned about you see so if we have
changes in climate we can have dengue
Zeke and she could win a more spread
like have Peaks all over the year so
it's even worse they have just during
this summer local shop and house owners
do their bit for the project the
mosquito traps scattered about the city
are emptied regularly and their contents
later examined in the lab the scientists
had established that in the areas where
the infected mosquitoes have been
released into the environment while back
here bacteria and are present in the
bulk of the mosquito population now the
scientists have to wait until the next
epidemic of a mosquito-borne disease in
humans to see if there's a reduction in
infection rates in those areas
every time you go for like a meeting
inside the community to have health
agents around they say that the health
clinics we are working like close they
are receiving less cases than the other
ones where robach is not established the
first positive results of a project that
might eventually be introduced in cities
around the world
banishing dengue zika and chikungunya to
the past
you